[Applause]
[Music]
all right so Happy Hanukkah everybody so
my name is Jojo and I'm the founder and
CEO of unroll dot me for you for those
of you who don't know what unrolled on
me is we're a consumer app that shows
you a list of all your newsletters from
Facebook to LivingSocial to Groupon
whatever you don't want it's a one click
unsubscribe whatever you do want but you
don't want cluttering up your inbox
you've been combined into a single daily
digest that we call the roll up and this
is my unexpected journey and yes that is
me on Bill Bell I love my designers do
that and hopefully I don't regret it
so I was a college kid living with my
parents in Brooklyn I was studying
philosophy at Brooklyn College and I
thought that HTML was something you need
to get vaccinated for I seriously went
into this industry not knowing what HTML
was but everyone starts somewhere you
don't need to have an amazing degree you
don't even need to finish college you
don't need to have a tech background or
come from a wealthy family and this is
my adventure
as an entrepreneur so chapter one it all
starts with the idea despite my lack of
tech chops I was always fascinated by
the web I was amazed that you can build
a website and millions of people across
the globe can see it and at the time I
thought it was like a push of a button
I didn't understand what scaling was but
that really fascinated me because if I
wanted to open up a coffee shop let's
say often a culprit coffee shop down the
block from here I need one coffee shop
here if I wanted to be in LA I mean it
was so operational intensive to get over
there so tech really fascinated me I
actually started my first business in
high school as a spammer not actually a
spammer but my friend Charlie and I got
together and I come from a very small
Jewish community in Brooklyn and people
wanted to advertise that to the
community members but had no way of
doing it online so we went out and we
collected thousands and thousands of
emails from people the community
hustling in every way possible I
through yearbooks to get emailed to had
to sell the back of yearbooks I went to
conferences and got people's emails from
conferences and we if someone wanted to
build an ad we had an ad and we sent an
email from to them so I went from
sending people emails for a living to
helping people get rid of the emails and
now back to our story the beautiful
Jerusalem this is my best friend Josh
and this is what brought us together and
yes that is a blackberry how many people
here had a blackberry at some point in
their lives
that's a nice amount so we were in
Israel together we were about a hundred
people and only two people in the entire
school had a blackberry me and Josh
so our rabbi came to I said guys I got a
little bit of advice for you and you
know when your rabbis telling you want
to be a good Jewish boy you're gonna
listen to your rabbi
he's like Jojo Josh you both have
blackberries and you both like business
be friends oh you left all right we'll
give it a shot it was love at first
sight we figured out that our birthdays
were both December 30th 1989 and we
stayed up the entire night watching the
first season of Gossip Girl later on we
ended up going to burgers bar for
breakfast lunch and dinner and we really
became very good friends two years later
we decided to that's life broken but
we'll go with it anyways we decided to
start a company together but instead of
building one company our idea was we're
gonna build 12 companies in one year
because 99% of startups fail so chances
are better if we build one company a
month we had no idea how hard it was to
build a company but we gave it a shot so
we hired a couple of engineer's off of
Craigslist and we thought we're
entrepreneurs we're gonna make it happen
our first thought it was called wearing
social we connected to your social media
accounts and helped you wear your
identity so we took for example all your
profile pictures and created a big
Facebook like sign it failed pretty
quickly but the concepts still cool and
maybe one day we'll bring it back in
actually so Josh and I were emailing a
lot back and forth to try and figure out
startup ideas but this guy would not
answer
any of my emails seriously he would get
pissed at me if I'd answer one of his
emails but we were sending ideas back
and forth together and it just never got
answered sorry I remember I called the
guy yelled but I'm like Josh you want to
start 12 startups in a year but we can't
communicate because you're not answering
my emails at the same time Josh went to
a conference if someone told him help me
unsubscribe with my emails do something
to help me unsubscribe my emails and
light bulb went off and that was the
first logo of enrollment right the yarn
ball I still love it and we have to
bring the old t-shirts back because I
don't have anymore
it actually took us a full month to come
up as a name for enrollment right we
thought that we would have 12 startups
in a year one startup a month and took
us a full month to come up with a name
it's impossible to find a domain name
these days every dot-com is taken and we
tried everything
unsubscribe me unsubscribe err every
single possible the domain name was
taken if we wanted a dot-com and then we
figured out okay you enroll in two
emails and you unroll from emails and
bam we just went for it
first thing was it had to be simple I
wanted every single person to be able to
use unroll me no matter what device you
use no matter who you are and no matter
where you live but I really wanted to
make sure that this lady could use it
and that beautiful lady is my mother and
she is the best and she is now a power
user
my mom has trouble turning on her
computer but she is a power user so on
one of our biggest outages everyone's
emails are hanging their inbox my mom
sent in a support ticket and if you can
read it it says a lot of emails that I
put in my roll up are coming into my
inbox you know what my mom's complaining
we're in trouble but at least she gave
me up is Joe Joe's mom lol you know
thank your mom and now was about looking
at the competition who's out there what
are they doing what are they all about
so first we saw unsubscribe calm they
were the biggest in the space they
raised a few million dollars we get a
download a plug-in what it was only
worked on your desktop I was using email
on my phone
I wasn't the right solution fun fact
James siminoff who started on subscribe
calm and end of failing
started ring years later and sold to
Amazon for over a billion dollars this
year so it all starts with email guys
then there was other inbox aw they're
always a lot better but it was all about
moving messages from your inbox into
another inbox folder and we still
thought that wasn't enough so this was
the first prototype of unroll made and
this logo never went live
the prototype never went live but it
gives you the basic idea Microsoft Dell
Apple you just click what you don't want
right you click what you don't want and
one click unsubscribe and then we get
you to inbox zero and that was it that's
where it all started now on to chapter
two but let me grab a drink of water
quickly but everything was great until
it wasn't we decided to launch our alpha
site and make an invite only because
that was a cool ship back in the day I
remember like five ten years ago
everything was invite-only but we also
use this our advantage and this is what
we did the entire throughout the entire
life cycle of unroll mate so we wanted
to create buzz and we want to get a lot
of press for our launch so instead of
just emailing TechCrunch and Mashable
and Lifehacker like hey we're launching
a start-up with no funding but it helped
people with email we said this is a
closed beta and is invite only but the
first thousand people that come via the
TechCrunch article the Mashable article
the Lifehacker article getting free and
cut the line and this really helped us
have a huge launch and it really was
enormous we were covered all over the
place right our servers crashed I didn't
know what HTML was but I had to like
come in and try to be an engineer to
solve these problems
and I would say it's like when everyone
here is going to try and get press when
you're trying to get think about a
TechCrunch writer how many emails are
getting is every day figure out what you
can give them to get their audience
excited that's more than just your
product but there's always something
that you can give
to make your launch really successful
and I remember you get on TechCrunch I
thought I was that was it I'm gonna
retire now I'm on TechCrunch you know it
was invincible and then we went and
decided to present at New York tech day
a New York tech day is an amazing
conference that had a couple hundred
startups in science and a science fair
like atmosphere presenting and we were
probably the least impressive startup at
the event but we came to win there were
VCS there were judges there were
reporters you know people looking for
jobs and we're like what are we gonna do
to stand out how are we gonna make it
that every single person that is at that
event is gonna be talking about on Romi
and how can we be unconventional because
everyone goes and they give out that you
know the the credit card holders and the
stickers but what were we gonna do that
was going to be different so I had my
friends come in and dress up in costume
we had my friend Jimmy dressing up as a
trashcan we had someone dressing up as
you know that mr. spam I had a friend
dressed up in like you know Captain
Underpants costume to help kill spam and
then we went one step further and we
replaced all the toilet paper at the
conference with on Romi branded toilet
paper
and seriously this was what everyone was
talking about no one was talking about
our startup no one's or any other stuff
there talk about on Romi is crazy they
replaced all the toilet paper in the
conference with our toilet paper and we
ended up winning we did it right again
well I was that excited that I lifted up
the trophy dropped it and has a big
crack right down the middle but it's all
it's all about the memories but
seriously the next time anyone here is
presenting at a conference we probably
spent the least amount of money on that
on that event all right we bought 20
rolls of toilet paper and went to Party
City to get some costumes you think
about doing something different that's
gonna let you stand out right how do you
be the the company that people are
talking about at the conference so after
the conference we were so hot we had
40,000 people on the waiting list I was
ready to buy my Ferrari pop the
champagne
I thought Steve Jobs was gonna call me
up and ask me to take you no charge and
we decided obvious we weren't that cool
but we decided to go all-in and I was in
college I was I had my senior year I was
actually studying for the LSAT I didn't
actually want to be a lawyer and thank
God I'm not because now I just get sued
all the time and not what I want to do
but like I'm a Jew in New York I faint
every time I see blood so if I'm not
gonna be a doctor I guess I'm gonna be a
lawyer and it was time to do it I
dropped out of college and I still have
three classes left that I promised my
wife I'll finish so I'll make it happen
at some point but I was just too
passionate about on Romi for it to be a
side project all right it's very
important to be passionate about what
you're doing like you see that heart
over there
that's how passionate I still am about
on Romi and what we were doing and now
building the company with my best
friends having a great co-founder is
super important and being successful
startup all right there are so many ups
and downs there are so many things that
you're doing and this is a person then
when there are ups you're celebrating
with but when the inevitable happen
there are downs that you're bringing
your you're bringing each other up it's
very very important Josh trusted me with
a product and I trusted him with the
business and it really worked out well
for us so make sure that you have a
great co-founder when starting a company
so again we were riding high until we
talked to the guys with the money and it
really her guys it really did they told
us your startup sucks you can't make
money this will never grow you guys have
enough yet because we didn't we kept
going for more days that you're not
going to scale past a hundred thousand
users you need a technical co-founder
and I'm sure a lot of people here hear
that and you don't need a technical
co-founder because we didn't have one
no one will invest this is the tool it's
not a product and we kept hearing the
same things over and over and over again
and it was very very hard we always
thought if you build it they will come
you'll worry about everything else later
but again we kept hearing the same
things and imagine I had to go into the
team
and they knew we were had these VC
meetings but Ida tell them sorry guys
we're over 15 didn't raise a single
dollar we thought we were on top of the
world and now how do we overcome this we
really believed in what we were doing I
know this sounds obvious but if you have
fully bought into what you're doing as a
founder as an early employee for a
start-up things will get hard there's no
one has instant success in the startup
world you're gonna get turned down from
some VCS you're going to have points
where like your servers just crashed and
you have you haven't nowhere to go
you're never done where it's like it
just feels so hard what the hell am I
gonna do take it over it if you believe
in what you're doing it'll make this
process so much easier so now into
chapter 3 the breakthrough so we were
scrappy and we were determined we were
gonna prove them wrong we're gonna do it
Everett took to make sure that we can go
back to these VCS and show them
everything that they said were a problem
we solved at the same time we had to
listen to their feedback
you know vici they're smart they know
what they're talking about they see
thousands of startups a year but they
told us so much you gotta build a
product you gotta grow fast you gotta
make money
engage your users like we're four people
on the team how are we going to do that
and that's what we learned how important
it was to prioritize correctly
everyone has limited resources no matter
if you're a two-person team a 50-person
team a 200-person team you can't do
everything you need to focus and you
need to prioritize well so we decided to
focus on two areas on making the best
product possible and to grow to profess
and we said if we have a great product
and we're growing super fast we can go
back to the VCS and finally raise around
and that's what we did
first we look at our data and we were
surprised to find that people only
unsubscribe from 30% of their
subscriptions or like everyone's telling
us that they have thousands of emails
that they don't want and they want
unsubscribe from all them so why are
they only unsubscribe from 30% and we
spoke to them and found out that people
didn't want to miss the deals for all
their subscription they were scared to
hit that unsubscribe button but they
still didn't want it in their inbox and
that's when we came up with a concept of
the roll-up
so the roll-up combines all of your
emails into one daily digest so instead
of getting 50 emails you got one and you
never miss out on a deal again that made
us from a tool into a product the next
thing was how are we gonna grow I was
never a believer that people just share
a product because they love it there are
certain people that that are active on
social and they're going to share things
that they love but people like my mother
people like my wife even like myself we
don't just share things that we love on
social media how are we gonna get there
so we look for inspiration looked at
Dropbox looked at the uber of the world
the list of the world and they were
offering you know if you share for every
user you get to sign up for Dropbox is
free space for you know oberon left you
get right credits but we were a free
product what were we gonna do and I also
didn't like the fact that it was a it
wasn't instant that I had to wait until
someone actually signed up for me to get
my credit so we thought very hard and we
came up with a four share we thought
what if instead of having a pay wall we
had a share wall
well users hate it can we get users to
share and we said we were gonna try but
we were nervous every advisor we had
said this was going to be the death to
unroll me they said people are gonna
hate it
you're focusing on growth more than
focusing on the product it's gonna be
the end of enrollment but we're like
let's let the data give us the answers
and that's what we did we found that at
once the users see their subscriptions
and also start from 5 newsletters that
they felt the magic and they're willing
to share at the time of launching the 4
share 90% of users who hit the share
wall shared and I was like what are they
sharing on Facebook or Twitter all right
50 it was 50/50 at the time but for
every hundred users that was share on
Twitter you would get one user in return
versus every 100 use that was sharing on
Facebook you would get anywhere between
80 and 150 users and return depending on
how many we're sharing at the same time
so we switch up the design and if you
can see here we had to share on Facebook
and then our other options this brought
us from 50% sharing on on Facebook to
over 80% sharing on Facebook
took on Romi viral so when we were able
to get one big burst you know a
TechCrunch article a Today Show we had
so many people sharing at the same time
that it was at the top of everyone's
newsfeeds
if I had to pick one thing for the
success of unroll me it's the for share
we figured out a way to get majority of
our users to share the service within
the first five minutes of signing up
alright so I made that sound easy but
what would I do today if I was trying to
die the next four share and you know
across industries the first thing I
would do is find the social incentive
all right what can you give to your user
that's going to incentivize them to
share alright if you're a free product
you know maybe you unlock features to
share if you're a paid product I would
challenge people here instead of doing
the typical model of you know you have
to invite someone and once they come
then you'll get credit give them instant
gratification you share you get a 5%
discount you share you get $1 off I give
them something right then in there
because again the people aren't just
going to share you because you have a
great product you got oh you got to give
them a push the second one is make sure
when you before you push up to share you
find the earliest time in the process of
once you gain their trust right for us
it was they see the magic of the
subscriptions they start seeing that on
Romi is working by pressing the
unsubscribe button and now they trust us
to go and ask them to share and they're
more likely to share it so do some
research look at the data and make sure
that you're asking the users to share
once they once they trust you and move
beyond Facebook Facebook took us viral
but Facebook is very different these
days is much harder to go viral on
Facebook right the algorithms have
changed the usage on Facebook has
changed look into alternatives like
whatsapp Facebook Messenger look into
you know just text messages and email so
now on to chapter four after the four
share we were growing rewriting
thousands of users a day we had our
first million users and things were
things were looking good problem was how
the hell are we keeping up our servers
without being able to hire we were an
unfunded team just had a friends and
family around
and trying to compete with hiring
against Google and Facebook was
practically impossible so we really had
to think differently of who we were
hiring it's all about the people right I
am very passionate about my team I love
my team and they're the ones that built
unroll me not me right I help guide them
through the process but building a great
team
is it the really way that you you could
succeed just like I said you have to
love what you do to me is even more
important to love the people you work
with and still to this day love the
people with I work that I work with and
it bringing you to work every single day
our main philosophy I done Romy's
resumes right I don't I never had a
resume hopefully I'll never need a
resume but we're not looking for the
typical person I want to look for the
diamond in the rough I won't want the
person that's gonna go work at Google
right we can't compete with that
I want the person that maybe didn't
study computer science in college right
and took a coding class but really wants
to do something different and really
wants to hustle and work their butts off
to take it to the next level and that's
what we did out on row me and one of the
perfect examples is Jack who's in the
audience today Jack you're the best Jack
was an intern for us and he ran part for
us for years he's one of the most
important people at unroll me and he did
it the unroll me way he came in he
worked hard he went from answering
support tickets to you know sending
t-shirts to to people on the you know to
some of our users - seriously leading
product and that's the way we did it and
I would say same for everyone here look
for alternatives look for different ways
to hire people look for that diamond in
the rough I take chances on people it's
worth it and basically hire smart people
you want to spend time with because we
love to spend time together you know
like we're a family or a family first
you know we had a Thanksgiving meal
together where everyone brought in a
dish from their house it was a lot of
fun and I can seriously talk about my
team forever because they mean the most
to me but I am gonna I'll move on on
this one and get back to the story so we
were doing pretty well in the tables
really turned and remember all those VCS
that turned us down
every single one turned us down they all
came back to us and the landscape
changed the auger in our favor
were we able to grow super fast now the
value of having users you know email
data start to really perk up right there
are companies like slice that raise
there was 30 million dollars to try and
build the nielsen of online right
companies like Procter & Gamble were
able to see what Huggies is doing versus
pampers at the Walmart stores but they
weren't able to see what it was doing
online so slice built a company to
extract information from email receipts
and help brands with market research
data to understand how they're doing in
the market and we were the one who the
users so we ended up being the swing
state so now we had to decide do we
partner with one of these companies do
we raise a VC round and try to you know
monetize ourselves or do we get acquired
and just focus on the user and we chose
acquisition main reason for choosing
acquisition is we want to do what we did
best and that is user user user let
someone else figure out the business
model and seriously our acquisition
story is like a freakin movie and I
still can't believe what happened and
how stressed I was because I was going
on my honeymoon at the time also so it
was really stressful the first company
that we signed a letter of intent with
we we're and due diligence for over
three months and it wasn't a good fit
now they're great people and I respect
them a lot but we just didn't see eye to
eye they didn't see us they saw said the
number the number of users they didn't
see the value in the team they wanted us
to come in rip up the culture and do
things their way
but what really took it what really
pushed it overboard
was how they were treating our people I
remember the first week after signing
the letter of intent we asked them
everyone on our team was getting
underpaid because unfunded start up how
much can you pay people so we said we
need to get people to market rate and
they kept pushing that conversation
pushing that conversation pushing that
conversation until three months after
due diligence where they sent everyone
their offer letters and it was like
raising people by five percent so I got
on a call to try and push that and
change it I didn't work and they said
Jojo as long as you come were happy so
we decided we're team see you later and
we walked away and that was hard because
I had to go into the team and tell him
this
we were working on for three months it's
gone we're walking away but we were in
it together and we made it happen
together so was at the end of the road
what would happen next to unroll me we
found the right partner we saw that a
company slice got acquired by Rakuten
seriously all we did was email the
founder saying congratulation guys were
so happy for you
five minutes later get a phone call from
harpy and Scot two of the founders Jojo
Josh you guys still available or like I
guess so like give me a number this with
a Thursday give us until Sunday night
and we'll have a letter of intent for
you so first things first we gave him
the salary numbers that we wanted
everyone on our team to have and they
approved it on the spot and said this is
your team your decision we trust you and
they went for it and then we gave him a
number that we thought they wouldn't
reach they said yes on Sunday night we
had a we had a letter of intent and the
rest is history and it's been amazing
for us at Rakuten slice you know they
really let us continue to be
entrepreneurs even though you know Scott
harpy Eric and Ben were founders that
have done this multiple times you know
they're all they're all teachers at
Stanford they're now partners in Eric
Schmidt's fund innovation endeavors have
sold multiple companies but they trusted
these 24 year old hustlers with no
experience to run the company and let us
do what we wanted to do they mentored us
and they really let us grow into who we
are today but most importantly they
cared about the people and we were very
aligned on the people and it's been an
amazing experience for me so once we do
post acquisition we went and finally
launched our iOS app it's crazy that it
took us like six years to launch an iOS
app but we did it and we did the way
that we always did at the unconventional
way and we wanted it we came in to win
it and we ended up being bigger than
Gmail and snapchat for one week at the
top of the App Store we were eighth
overall in the App Store
[Applause]
so we went from not knowing what hTML
was to 8th overall in the App Store and
we have two joint project cross country
with a slice team and the unroll me team
coming together and building a product
and it was really really awesome it's
been an awesome adventure for us and
unroll me is still going strong
we have over 3.7 million active users
we've been mentioned in the press over
fifty eight hundred times and we process
over a hundred and twenty-five million
emails per day so now what what lessons
can you take from this first one and
I'll keep repeating this one even though
I think you know I like it's pretty
typical believe in what you do
startup life is tough right major major
roller coaster ride and if you don't
fully believe in the company that you're
working for once things get hard you're
not going to be the ones that are able
to like jump past it
make sure you believe in what you do be
unconventional I would challenge
everyone here the next time that you're
at an event do something different right
if it doesn't work the next event do
something different what's going to make
you stand out and don't overthink it
have someone freaking dress up in a
costume I do your own version of the
toilet paper is done I stand out there's
so many startups these days it's so
important to be able to stand out and
share figure out a way to get your users
to share in ways that people aren't
doing take a chance don't just look at
what's out there and do it that way take
a chance and be unconventional and
surround yourself by the right people
most importantly I make sure that you
work with people you love people that
you're going to fight the battles with
people that you're going to celebrate
with people are you gonna cry with these
are the people that you're gonna be with
every single day you're from your
co-founder who is like a spouse right to
your team who's like your family to the
people that eventually will acquire all
of your companies out there make sure
you surround yourself with people that
you love thank you everyone
again my name is Joe Joe feel free to
reach out to me
and guys because I'm not taking
questions I'll be around for lunch so if
anyone has questions you could tweet at
me email me or just find me over here
all right thank you everyone thanks for
letting me speak